beaucoup de julie du tu m'as fait peur
j'étais en train de me demander de quel
côté se mettait le couteau et la
fourchette par rapport à l'assiette a
bien c'est simple
il faut tenir le couteau de la main
droite pour couper plus facilement alors
on le place à droite de la sienne oui et
la fourche à ta gauche c'est compris le
but évidemment ce tube est titulaire non
je commande capable de terminer tout
seul importe merci je lis alors la
fourchette à gauche le couteau à droite
le couteau à droite la fourchette à
gauche la fourchette à gauche le couteau
à droite le couteau à droite elle la
fourchette à gauche le couteau à droite
la fourchette à gauche plutôt à droite
les fourchettes à gauche couteau
derrière et la fourchette bleue non non
je vous en prie monsieur juste vous avez
vous et tout mélanger non
musulmans biais pardon j'ai du snob il
faut que ce tacle impeccable rien à
redire c'est qu'aujourd'hui c'est
l'anniversaire de mademoiselle futex
n'est pas une raison françois pour
tourner autour de la table et faire deux
fois le couvert enfin voyons je voudrais
pas arrêter vous entendre tourner non
c'est vrai c'est vrai monsieur 10,9
j'aurais dû prendre un point de repère
avant de commencer mon tour de table
évidemment cela vous aurait permis de
voir où vous deviez commence merci du
conseil monsieur les snobs merci rythme
qu'avez-vous là dans votre carton à
dessin et bien c'est un cadeau pour
mademoiselle futé un cadeau puisse
savoir ce que fait que vous êtes
curieuse mademoiselle julie et bien je
vais vous dire ce sont des gravures qui
représente des pâtes d'animaux
montrez-nous ça continue ça me voilà
c'est une pâte de quoi et bien chers
amis je vous avoue humblement que je ne
sais pas monsieur du snuff votre cadeau
aurait beaucoup plus de valeur aux yeux
de mademoiselle futaie si vous pouviez
lui dire les noms des animaux justement
vous croyez eu écoute et vous dire une
chose appelons les enfants j'allais lui
proposer eh bien allez vous installer
sur le banc moi je vais chercher à plat
pour le gâteau d'art sera fait les
enfants les enfants venez avec nous
venez vite lesieu du snob a besoin de
vous
il ya là dans ce carton à dessin les
dessins de pâtes d'animaux exactement
fait raison mais monsieur du snob ne
connaît pas leurs noms ou les biens
étaient bien commençons par la première
quel est le nom
[Musique]
sauvage avec un air sauvage c'est pas ça
c'est pas tout à fait ça c'est la patte
d'un manchot aussi dix neuf mais je vous
le remet pas
très bien c'est d'une patte de cheval à
votre avis c'est l'avant ou l'arrière
c'est d'une patte arrière il a
parfaitement raison
c'est pas une autruche mais ces oiseaux
oui un échassier c'est une cigogne le
pâté 2,6 gagnés comme hello je le savais
j'ai la mi temps de voir la ceca marche
ça
tu réponds très très vite mais il faut
laisser le temps à nos amis qui sont
chez eux de répondre c'est une pâte de
canard mais si les hommes
sont beaucoup plus forts que vous
monsieur des sceaux n'a connu ces chers
amis il nous reste des les formes j'en
suis pas persuadé monsieur du snob c'est
pas de là c'est une patte ça c'est
difficile oui tu vas donner la réponse
ne me lehner avance qu'une pâte douce
ruche panucci a vu des chiens et pas de
quoi vous donner mes 6 9
c'est une patte de chat c'est une pâte
avant une patte arrière somme
tu as raison de 15 ans est une pâte à
dent
enfin la dernière
[Musique]
c'est bien une police à la vente la
tarière
loudervielle betty une patte arrière
devant devant ils ont des toutes petites
pattes comme ça oui
tu as raison
merci les enfants on peut les jouer
maintenant très gentil je vous remercie
là encore françois ils sont gentils 1
vous allez pouvoir briller aux yeux de
mademoiselle futaie ah oui il faut vite
aller chercher mademoiselle futa
maintenant oui oui mais j'ai pas vu
casimir ou est-il dont casimir est parti
acheter des bougies pour les mettre sur
le gâteau d'anniversaire de manon cette
fuite est de toute façon ne vous
inquiétez pas il n'est pas perdu il faut
que nous allions chercher mademoiselle
futé et je suis sûr qu'en revenant il
sera là allons-y vitrac
[Musique]
pour
oui oui
à
casimir vite donne moi les bougies mais
moi c'est le futé arrive avec françois
et monsieur snob moment malheureusement
je lis un je n'ai pas trouvé de bougies
mais c'est épouvantable à un gâteau
d'anniversaire sans logis ça ne signifie
rien qu'allons-nous faire ne t'en fais
pas j'ai résolu le problème qu'est ce
que tu as fait et bien pour qu'il n'y
ait pas de gâteau 100 bougies j'ai j'ai
mangé gapeau
[Musique]